welcome back to las vegas now with this
heat and sunshine quality shutters are a
necessity for your home sunburst
shutters and window fashions the
sponsors of this next segment has you
and your windows covered check it out
[Music]
okay john last time i was here you kind
of gave me a tour showed me around
showed me the products now
i'm ready to buy great i am a customer
we're ready to sell to you okay so
what's the process like so the process
is you call the store
367-1600 and our people will set up an
in-home design consultation it's
absolutely free okay and we'll send a
professional out and they'll talk to you
about what your needs are some people
are all about color and other people are
interested in light control and some
want energy efficiency and somewhat all
of the above so depending on what your
needs are we'll offer you a couple of
ideas and some solutions that will take
care of them you pick what you want we
go and build them everything's custom
built we don't do anything we don't
build anything before we come out and
then when we're ready when it's all done
then we'll call you to come out and
install and we take care of all the
installation effort as well wow so you
just sit back
we take care of everything you pick and
we do all the work so then what makes
you guys what makes your product you
know the best for las vegas homeowners
in particular yeah well sunburst
shutters has a number of exclusive
products to us
most were designed by us
pollywood shutters is the most common
and pollywood is is better than any
other shutter for a number of reasons
first of all it's built to last it's a
little thicker it's more durable
it's got a paint finish that's actually
chemically bonded to the material so
that it will never discolor it's never
going to peel it's never going to chip
and no one else can say that just
sunburst so the other thing is we
extrude our product with weather
stripping on it so when it closes it
closes tight and it offers more energy
efficiency than any other shutter no one
else does that it's all sunburst another
thing that separates sunburst shutters
from the crowd is every one of our
people are a full-time employee we don't
hire subcontractors
they work for us they do shutters all
the time so you're going to get the best
service because they know what they're
doing and they take care of the customer
every time warranties for life
but if there is an issue
what do you do if there's an issue give
us a call we'll send a team out usually
it's a small thing and we'll take care
of that and and honestly what kind of
small things a small thing could be a
louver pin
that's slipped a little or maybe a
staple from the tilt rod that's easy to
take care of and we'll do it every time
so honestly in all the years i've been
here we've very rarely had a warranty
issue but every time we've taken care
well i feel very taken care of i'm ready
for my new shutters and we are in your
showroom
typically typically your customers just
call up and get a consultation you guys
come straight to their home but they
also have this as an option we'd invite
anyone to come to the showroom this is
where you can touch and feel and kind of
pick some options and colors and kind of
see everything that's available and make
your selection before we even get to
your home
thank you to sunburst shutters for
sponsoring that segment give them a call
at
702-367-1600 or just head to sunburst
shutters las vegas dot com and check out
this special offer mention you saw this
on las vegas now and save up to 500
on your pollywood shutter order minimum
order required though okay